you
Sobel's thank you for the prime sub and
Ellen Paul Morphy one thank you for the
primary sub two months in a row you ad
I'm back you are thank you ma'am
what move was missed
I'll let you guys know what stock fist
that might be an emo I might have just
found a new emo
watch out for stock fist
I'll keep this guy around I'll keep the
pin playing against buster DX
Ron right the apon see what happens
Oh an in-betweener who's gonna win the
in-betweener race though I take here
take there I take care
chop-chop-chop
you
who
you
mmm-hmm-hmm can't take with the Queen
hmm
[Music]
fish up here
looks interesting
I spent way too much time there
let's see I mean if that to take here
I'm just I'm up upon so
let's find out are we both going to get
cleans on the board chop chop chop chop
chop chop
I get the clean though you know get my
Quinn
all right throw
back to Buster and seeing what Buster
comes up with all right I got to take
you
hmm
I was thinking this move
you
and seen
you
I mean there's this but I have this
hitting the Queen hang the bishop still
very tricky because this pawn is still
around
like what
about this move
and trouble
you
that
you
okay
you
I'll take with the rook
you
I guess
kay bat move
you
so we take and then take that pawn
finally
double up okay well we're even material
I like my position though
opposite color bishops I this guy I hope
is going to be a target soon
I can win this pond now
I should be the one pressing for a win
this rook has to stay tied down here
just four versus three as well
- April wanna win this palm I don't know
if I even care about the winning that
pond I care more about this
let's get a flight square
I'll recapture on whichever rook they
take I want to keep a rook on the
seventh
beware the time
you
let's just step up
you
prove the king
you
you
I was already thinking my bishop was
here
hello
you
okay light squares
you
you
fish up here and then here
[Music]
you
well they gotta go into
pin
they're in a they're in a pretty big
pickle here
you
and that's me
oh I don't know those complications yeah
that our middle game
our ponds going into pacman mode
I'm not sure
I'm not sure who should really come out
ahead with that I think I was actually
more vulnerable I think there were
I think there were more opportunities
for black along that
and somewhere along that variation where
there were improvements or improvements
for black and white
something with their pawn capturing on
b7
think like for example after they after
I recapture my clean maybe taking
if this pawn is still on its home square
this is a blunder but not here I'll just
go back home take
make sure this guy is here so this is
basically
this guy's playing better than his
rating feel that's a very good move
I like the timing of it
um I play here
you
try that
okay
I'm just going to take that I'm fearful
of some quick pressure
against my night
okay it's still there
all right there is a
waste there that wasn't yet a threat
because I was still in a pen
here
we'll go here always have to be careful
this idea
carting it
there's a fork Mumbi - I don't know if
I'm I really want to grab that guy
it's why we're taking this though take
the bishop
let's push
there's some kind of stuff like this but
I'm up a couple pawns so even if I go
down the exchange got a pass or no okay
change prove the knight got this covered
as smooth I could ignore take the clean
you got this pawn
I am up three pawns I'm on the night
neither side with a back
flight square yet
I have my pick take the rook
and now the night
I fell apart last few moves got may in a
few if Rick takes rook and just sweep in
move
made on h2 okay back to tournament land
AC Silva
let's try Knight f3 and a d4 areas the
speedy one
to a blazing start let's go to
hmm they're allowing me to
just jury captured the pond no no
problemo
let's give him a kick I know he has that
square but my bishop
at some point
let's put a little pressure on the light
squares
okay thing I want to jump around my
night just a little bit let's go here
and then here
instead of castles maybe this
immediately putting pressure I think
would have been maybe I could have been
inconvenienced okay so they're just
saying d4 is now rock
got a good point
try this maybe h4 Bishop g5 flight
square no light square for black
in a play for c5 I have this though
and take the night
and upon
may want to pause at this point instead
of grabbing here something else
probably not gotta get that guy back
up upon cleanness hits here's a blunder
they take my queen and then they take my
night so
no no no I have a move 96
maintain my queen position
yeah let's keep that night around
let's miss that one thing is good
here is looking dangerous
okay and I think taking with the pawn is
best
like my queen position still
so let's keep her in the center
and maybe we can slide into this square
controlling the promotion of the square
if this yep at least there are checks
one day
one of these two to defend the pawn or
eventually challenge the night
let's go here actually if I go here
there's night here you know probably
both are fun scare the night away
rook here is no good
night there
you
okay
you
let me let me give this check first
why why'd I do that
you
okay and then here
realcare drops the rook this tactic
isn't working because I could take rook
take side
oh my goodness that's kind of a big Fork
yeah
[Music]
Wow what a miss
oh man
okay you got me
you
gotta babysit
man oh man
you
you
all right I guess they could get the
rooks off if they want to
man
and I'm way down on the clock
you
Wow
hello and ilex scared about this stuff
maybe
you
it's not
you
I got nothing
ah man back to tournament why how that
big Fork
ah man
Oh
that's disappointing that's very
disappointing
okay try to get back on the horse
ah
and I was really back on the clock bad
position and bad on the clock kay let
that happen again
okay
go faster play better
is the only way
faster and better we'll see
so throw the bishop there no more than a
few seconds
play
with your instincts
No
we'll go here maybe that
okay
let's dance with the night
take me
we have an even position exchange
oh you know what I could have played I
could have exchanged rooks and then
clean here clean before maybe nearby
okay I got a check there here let's see
what happens to play act clean here I
get this feels right okay so I go here
that has to go here
take the queen okay I'm spending more
than I said I would about this first I'm
on this pawn night spin I still have
pressure here pressure here
oh this would have been a blunder what
am I talking about hmm silly
you
No let's get the apon running
or I could have maybe just put pressure
on the a pond to
like yeah I'm trouble moving
I thought
night here
close to winning the the deep on
all right I could exchange Queens
and then when upon
you
here I'm going to tack the the pond like
this otherwise there might be this as a
counter-attack coming down both of these
squares sit twice this pawn is
controlling the night
and this nights under control so it's
that one they just drop the night
okay
I don't know if the activity really
should have amounted to me getting
something there I mean I don't know
maybe there was a defense there I had
some pressure in that Queen Queen and
Knight position okay
mmm best in blitz is playing 2784 blitz
rating was very high
does Jerry berserk rarely maybe this is
one of those times because my opponents
preserving
I sometimes berserk I berserk the other
day wasn't streaming
did a an all-out Berserker
here no matter what pretty much I get
this in I'm happy oh they have that move
Queens defending
good eye
I'll take now
I'll go here right now
a bishop the night
let's bring bring it back
control c5 that's very weakening
my night as dreams of getting to this
square let's go here first seems really
weird
but maybe I play for c6
let's go for c6
whoa pons pinned
take
take and then jump into this beautiful
square
here Queen on f4 is what I'm thinking
now Queen here I don't care about this
pawn at this point
I have my flight square let's get active
I'm on the night
take here any back rank check my king
simply steps up they missed that I'm on
the night there
so this should collapse soon enough
you
all right
take with the night
you
as long as the queen can't get to these
two am i right making one threat
f2 okay see if we could get a four still
fishing for a four here
a lot more jumped in there that did not
take long
700-plus are in this tournament
still over an hour to go these are fun
I got to get back to playing some more
tournaments Krishna one two four four
what's going on
let's try Carole come
you
let's get the night out I like these
positions a lot exchange karo
SuperDuper solid for black
Ahn's here get your buck hassled
I reckon half-open file a lot of logical
moves
maybe this one not so logical
clamp no c4
ever see for this guy becomes isolated
what would I like to do here
get rid of their best piece get a night
here
blunder
sharp sharp nanoclay narc way
quite the
they were on my my bishop after that
rook recaptures
should be a nightmare bishop
let's get the flight square in now just
in case there's ever H six or h5 I have
that stop night here
pressure here a threat there let's
defend upon
I could win this pawn now
clean is hitting a lot
solid structure remains solid the more
active pieces these sacrifices don't
work my King steps up or my Bishop can
block
they're also on this know that the pawn
has moved
so upper rook and the Queen's are again
into Hungary bishop okay back to turn we
got a four
hello Chuck a DZ
happy to see me playing and streaming
it's fun
thanks fan door
KREM cakes hello to you
throws in the towel yes it's a new emote
the towel emote
let's take
and play Knight f3 and then e4
important there
otherwise there can be an eventually
five idea by black
taking up the Queen because this is the
Knights favorite square
so he's there in one move Bishop here
eventually the eyes will be opened with
the punch
right now let's say right now
and
play it how take the night after jumps
in here and then rooks see one no
they're not even playing there
so you know here
does that even do
let's play here actually this move that
prevents this would break that move I'm
not really too concerned about what's
this Knight going to do
let's just come back
so this is a weak point to pinpoint that
this is a struggling piece
I had prepared to meet that with c5 with
the d5
and I think this works
I am helping this bishop in night out
though hmm
what do I do I just move my bishop No
here there's night there
I don't care about that
I'm here here I just back off
and really play that
yeah I only calculated this capture but
maybe they could play c4 that's that's
pretty good
I probably could have done something
different here to have to retreat in
this position even for a move like that
I have probably done something wrong
okay
and now the other night's gonna have a
great square yeah I definitely miss
played this
okay well let's try this
maybe they invite my bishop back
this diagonal
just maybe okay I could capture here
though No
let's try that
you
now I'm ready to take care
hmm gone wrong here
her black these last couple moves
one two pounds
you
well let's see if they take me give me
the file nope
all right I'm gonna say let's back off
both of these Knights aren't controlled
by two pawns two points controlling six
points
oh here clean here then I have to worry
about the capture
you
and let's just babysit the seafloor pond
for right now my nice remain good got
all my center points can under control I
could take here with check that was
maybe a bad decision it's too fast with
that
I was too fast
maybe I go on castled
yeah
as covers my queen and king now
now maybe looking at a
move
this diagonal for a moment and then
Queen h6 looking at the G g7 square as
otherwise running in here fast is going
to allow Queen takes Knight widths check
so I'm not here right now is what I'm
referring to so this now takes here I
don't have the Queen is there
you
um maybe I just moved the night
you
let's move the pond first all my time my
time and I hear to hear frack here
or smothered mate
forget about the position time
let's go here
all right now there's no pressure on my
knight anymore clean here is like there
could be a clean sacrifice nearby check
scare that night away always block clean
check couple ways here oh I had queen
takes rook whoops
that's me got to close actually I got
two calls
okay any sincerity rules is their
sincerity rules has been playing for
team chest network in those team battles
he was uh played the first two and he
was all geared up I believe as well for
the third one that went
down as a disaster a berserk game oh I
would a berserk back I didn't have time
okay I'm not always the Reavers irking
type but I was I was prepared to write
then in there
okay
these guys are on its hair the Ferrari
33 let's jump in I don't want to see
this break this break isn't in this
bishop could still find it difficult to
do something exciting okay once more
notice this situation here this pawn
controls the night
the Knights looking for some air it's
understandable
let's go here a night on this this
square is short-lived
I don't know why I didn't play this move
much sooner
hmm very tempted to take that uh now
let's go here
not here because of a fork but this numb
on the night in the brook
and the knight can't block that's a full
rook
all right and now now we're going to be
astute this time too
worker-owned ease
no fork on this square
um I guess I'll take
and grab that passer
I don't want to take that night okay
flight square take the clean grab a poem
and convert
don't get back
made it
let's get a flight square
and then we'll think about aggression
check here
don't allow the
to get to f3 don't even allow that guy
to get here shop
chap here no King loud just take I don't
want to even see this run run run run
okay they resigned 21:9 over 900 in
there
Evon zero four six five thanks for the
hundred bits you add happy to catch a
tournament stream learn so much watching
all your tournament videos on YouTube
chef MD one thank you for the 100 bits
you add from my daughter Violet watching
you hello violet thank you for tuning in
spanky one thank you for the 100 bits
all right
hello Neil the seal in the chat
let's go a g6
all right they're going with the setup
favorite of mine
probably play it too much
and conservative
I'm in this pin but it's not a it's not
one that could really be exploited
move
you
see if I could get these moves in
take towards the center I don't care
about development with tempo against the
Queen
let's go here I weakened this but I want
to prevent be for I want to be able to
take and then take here so if I stop
this move that means eventually this is
a backward pawn in a forever sore spot
and White's camp
look at a pinpoint this and this is a
very healthy straw
sure of six nice pawn island
the only weak point is here but it's not
accessible the e-file isn't half open
for example
no Bishop here or anything so this is
blundering two pawns actually
and to be
you
okay is there something better than rook
takes B
see it
this
you
get some material
two pawns and the exchange okay they
resign back to turn rule and where page
one
ah there's the best in blitz he's on a
100% berserk ray
currently in a game what the fast and
furious one
I wonder if you berserk that one
all tasks beating the Ferrari with only
90 seconds
you
okay the stench
all right
yes they chopped their
you
I think night here prevents my bishop
this quick pressure against this point
prevents
prevents Bishop to f5 because there's
this queen bee through this timely Queen
b3 move
I guess I'm going for a Ponce
face
just how it is
that suppose I take here
seems right
and if I take here
oh no no I have a slick move I think
hmm if I take here and the bishop goes
here
we may have some tactic based on these
unprotected rooks
could take here than this
or even here I don't hear Bishop move
you
you
hmm
let's say let's take here
took a lot of time this might be my
king's home and I like this is a better
shelter than the White kings
oh it's just playing the
straightaway
yeah you make a good point okay
I understand king f7
tea
for a coin exchange
can't be declined because I get the rook
let's play in the center
I don't want to see this break
Nina's going to be a race isn't it
let's go here
I don't know I don't know I don't know
can stop the rook entering over here I
gotta go much faster
you
you
want to be prepared to get out and get
the a file if this break is hitting
you
here yeah I'll try for this I was
thinking about this but I guess that's
too easily defended let's try to get my
night here hope that a night getting to
this square is it's still long off and
it is
you
us
you
pawn
you
prove the king if here then rook here to
here why didn't I take the a file all
right let's try for this now here takes
the push
to passers they could get a pastor as
well but my rook is ideally placed
behind mine
a check this is Kim I think my pond has
gone too far
you
okay my can't get stopped this guy
we after this one
you
also I have this way to track down
the upon which I think is important also
I want to hold my king position to get
this this ID in mind first hold the king
from getting to this square
here here and then take
cos accurate ah I didn't play there
though I forgot to play there haha let's
run
you drop that poem
oh there's some messy moves by both of
us these last couple okay this is a win
though
hey yo Yaya
you
you
you
all right I don't have to do the
oilfield or I could have kicked them
back first either way there's plenty of
time
do I not a mate with the king and rook
not making the best moves here okay
now we're on the
the right path
the old waiting move and enough gas in
the tank for mate I said we get behind
the pond and then save my pond I didn't
date the pond okay
ah best in blitz did not berserk Ferrari
he thought better
he knows the Ferrari is fast Ferraris in
a game I might get the the best and
blitz guy is he in the game nope
probably get this pairing Stewart who
another beefy one in there a lexer 81
good turnout no none of the above 44 to
go all right let's go for
variation I don't have too much
first-hand experience with 92 to g3
I see the slippery penguin played a lot
we'll keep pieces on the board it's
usually a struggling piece
it's a very early
maybe I should have played this as soon
as I was in because now the night
wouldn't he wouldn't been able to block
there
just go here for a second just a second
just in case like if I do this too soon
maybe Bishop here is annoying okay
I played a four before a six there's
night here into this week square so
timing is important
seems another
what am I really doing with this bishop
here let's get him back here
let's get these guys going now whoa
really
giving up the dark-squared
surprising
push take take take bishop takes and
then I have this square that should be
excellent for me
Bishop takes c5 hits the rook with tempo
then I get on this long diagonal
I'm a strong night maybe I don't even go
here right I'm about clean here
Bishop Knight has to move back clean
here I have this there is no clean there
I'm on the rook they're just giving up
the rook
take it centralized the Queen this
nights not playing control this break
let's go one step
let's undermine that pawn I don't care
well that's not even upon loss but the
idea here is to get these guys rolling
they should be winning now should be
pretty clean
I'll see
on take Brooke tell
for Queen takes still this the wheels
are in motion
that night threatening
nothing let's just keep running
exchange Queens
take
a push
you
you
yeah let's just push steak here there's
pins
this guy
and push here's I just grabbed a piece
up a full rock now
let's go here
you
very king
could have also cut off the king there
time is okay
you
night is under control here
the rook in the night
trappin could try
you
script
you
and step up first
you
you
you
this is still I've managed to make this
still tricky why this was not a good
technique to trade off all the pawns
like that
I'm just asking to get a fork to end up
in a fork myself night here would be
helpful that would be helpful and we got
it okay we've been here before I think
about the last game rook and King versus
King
all righty
let's keep going let's keep going with
about d4
d4c for
all right Queens gambit declined
take
i QP position or not if here it's yes if
here it's no
another in-betweener all right I'll take
what then take with the night
sidestep any uh any of this take here
first
okay so they've avoided an IQ P position
let's just continue developing
alright I'll say you take me help me out
there okay they're not let's get on this
main diagonal here here right here
Oh No
I'm tick better slightly head in
development and there's still a problem
for for black to solve
I'll say let's go over right here if
they play this I could actually take
just back off but I could win this pawn
and my Queens position cannot be rattled
this pin can main can be maintained for
a mousou
yeah I can see why I could see why black
mr. Dai missed it initially as well
is prepared to go here
you
so it's a really big pond to lose
because now this guy's isolated weak
still in a pin
huge square on e4
let's go here maybe the wrong rook maybe
the better here
f2 may be sensitive we'll find out
yeah f2 could be sensitive now if I take
here Knight
has to take Queen takes island of land a
fork
you
you
yeah okay
let's start with this
Bishop's defended okay this was wrong
like what I did here was was wrong wrong
rook wrong rook
there's good
you
guess I'm coming back over clean here
here threatening mate of two can
collapse
still should be able to defend ejected
Lee but the time
a little behind here on the clock and a
play here
not on this anymore it's thinking him on
that
take out b7 to defend
I think the bishop in defending here
these sacrifices I could back off
you
clean g6
I may have to give up the rook for the
night if I want to play for a win
I think I will the time now turning
slightly in my favor yeah I'm gonna try
that
take another pond defend here
check
you
let's go clean here just want to get the
cleans off if I could even if it costs
upon all you could take here
just want to defend some squares this
and then here
you
defend my second-ranked in case there is
a queen exchange
you
around the Queen
you
bones are moving
you
here stopping this for the moment
you
came on that guy
it's nice tricky he's a tricky guy
and some coordination keep going phone
check
you
no time this guy's so fast
man that guy has wheels I forgot about
that guy haven't so that guy having so
many so many wheels he's really fast I
forgot how fast my opponent was a lexer
only lost to the best in blitz were over
1100 players in here
okay look at this guy in first twenty
four hundred flawless what's the
performance rating 2676 and I see some
fives in there as well
I think I went back and forth a bit too
much with my king there
I could have been risking
repetition
you
this month the e5 break-in they're free
either bishop
remove a big center pond and tuck the
Queen in on e7 we go from here where
does the bishop Paloma
I'll say right here I know preventing
this break may be vulnerable to this on
this next move not now flight square
let's go opposite the Queen
I'm not really concerned about
[Music]
about
battery my knight is a reliable defender
of h7
so
no problemo there
you
it's going to land in a fork
like I have this covered trying to
distract my bishop
let's keep going
thrown a lot of pawns at me
you
you
chop-chop boom check here check here
here here
you
and I'll pay
my king should be safe on e7 and I don't
even think I lose my g7 palm
and they're crazy
and here queen says she has to
she doesn't have a good check and then I
have-have this
my knight returns to this great square
there's no there's no follow-up piece no
other piece is connecting well with the
Queen she's all in
all by herself
not thinking about taking right now
only if it was a discovered check you
know
okay so the clean is just there yep
let's go here Queen takes I just win the
Queen
as I could just hide let's go here first
try to get the Queen's off
I miss that there's Queen here okay
let's just hide
upon
up a rook
you
okay back to turn
little calculation there - I don't know
don't I was tempted to just not take
that pond that was my initial but you
know
that was a moment to actually go ahead
and calculate see if you could actually
grab that guy
the jeep on was free
you
let's play this maybe we enter
structure I'm back off now
take that
no Bishop takes pawn now maybe I could
hang on to this guy
I'll try
on h7 mmm they missed that
tonight right here
you
I have to move just yet
let's just defend
any bishop move is a discovery I guess
we'll go here now
I even want that pond
think I like this
you
and now grab it
right there is own Nader
all right this is the top dog
he has getting berserk I'm not gonna
berserk back he's giving me some time to
think about it I've already thought my
way through it I'm not going to berserk
too scary you're having too good of a
run
all right
you
take here there
there
all right
it's the plan what's the plan
let's try this
it interferes with the Greek gift
sacrifice they're still angling for it
though
to play here
you
I guess clean here to here scary
ah
be prepared to play a five I'm not in
yeah they're just
throwing pawns at me I understand
what am I to do
here clean up 6
you
No
take care
you
you
here here check here I don't have a good
follow-up
that's what I was banking on
you
geez okay I don't know
all right
mmmm
you
you
you
gonna grab here cleans up
guess that guy's toast
now there was a most look they want to
grab that poem
you
you
you
that I was able to play here
or in the tank
oh man
now as a berserk game this guy done
sin paws mode is had enough
nearing 28
jus-just through every pawn at me I
think he had a mail slip in there he
wanted my rook pawn
all right French
advance
I'll take them and take care
see if I could get Bishop here will be
happy I'm happy
d4 I think is critical now it turns a
bit more static I think for these next
few moves and I have time to put my
pieces on decent squares like this
maneuver
you're gonna throw these guys at me I
don't know it's super committal but it's
something I have seen before all right
how to capture think the bishop here is
fantastic my knight may be on this
square is good mm-hmm
so if this guy if I can force this guy
to move this is going to hurt so what
can I do to rattle this this bishops
position
here here here is a sack no not seeing
that alright let's open up a maybe the
queenside
and let's keep going
fix that pond keep these guys disjointed
clean stepping up is with stump oh let's
do that
punch maybe this some weird like if
Queen here actually
that actually works here here here
check now the bishop could block
here here check
the king moved then I could take here
Amandla
I'm on the bishop and if the bishop
moves this
that's really close I think
clean takes here shag bishop they're
here
I'm gonna do it it's too hard and it did
not just play that move just grabbing
this this guy's close I have a passed
pawn rook activity the pieces are kind
of clumsy and go for it it's not
thoroughly calculated but it just looks
fun at minimum
I didn't calculate anything else besides
this so there could be this move too
that could hurt
you
save the night drift over here or
something it's in the tank yeah
there's a smart move
you
when you're still in the tank
okay let's see it's approaching bullet
time doesn't want the Queen you're
believing me don't believe me
don't be chicken
alright I'll save the queen
I got a pond clean takes up five okay
put another piece there maybe
check
now it's definitely winning I can take
care too
let's take the bishop the slick move
right interference
on the Queen on the bishop now
it's collapsing
all right back to Turner land Bastin
bullets went down whoo
Adam this guy Oh
game didn't even start maybe a
connection issue
I guess I'll go first Sicilian
Rocsi bind
hmm
all right
I go fishing let's try it it's been a
while
haiji for
take how take with the
I'll take with this SI phan build my
Center some
okay this is this could really be close
to mate soon
this stuff it's weakened their king
now let's just play to open up the
center
even if it costs upon it doesn't cost
upon immediately because there's a pin
here it's poison
so even in this position let's castle
even in this position if this guy falls
it's big trouble there's even scenarios
where the Queen could be sacrificed a
double bishop me
sky is worth five in this position it's
very important this guy this bishop is
in exchange for this guy where my knight
or a rook I feel in many cases
takes my rook is there hit I could play
here but what I want is this and then
here get that get this light squared
Bishop off
of this guy
a problem so I am down upon but it's
super scary for their king a lot of
pieces around still
not easy to develop pressure on b2 in
this open position you want to develop
but it's not easy
clean here clean they're clean there
I know on a clean exchange
I think it's okay I didn't see there's
that
all right
you
I'm going to keep the Queen's own
can I just get Bishop b7 I think I can
they finished harassing my queen
let's get them
it's now the queen
keep this clean on
I squared bishop exchange can't take
being me on g2
and the rook having to recapture it's
the queen who should occupy f3
okay take Queen takes I have this I'm on
the bish up to
a piece
Ferrari given this top guy a good run
66-65
twelve over 1200 under 12 minutes over
1200 in here
or I&C 3043 thank you for the tier one
sub appreciate it man
okay oh this is the guy that beat up
and blitz Grandmaster blessed in blitz
now decline it
you
starter
you
let's just play here Wow
maintaining the tension are we
maybe now I take
you
no exile just support it
so this pond needs to capture before
this guy and this guy can play so for as
long as this tension remains these two
are inconvenienced it's more of an
inconvenience for black to have this
tension on board than for me
I guess they're gonna force this
defender away from the pond nam ready to
take
so it's not without its issues this
launching of the Jeep on they've
castling kingside
and that's such a great choice anymore
[Music]
let's go here why not here I don't know
let's player right there
I should hear first
let's go Bishop here first
oh we've to be really careful well this
is maybe winning oh it is winning night
here Knight f6
I was ready to just retreat my first my
first thought here there's that it's
painful clean somewhere else there's
still a check and then I have a
discovery there's got to be a good
discovery no it's me it's from its mate
I control these two my Knights control
these two my queen will have these two
so I'm either winning the queen or the
king
maybe they could do some imbalance two
minor pieces for the Queen
I don't see how they get two minor
pieces for the Queen maybe this Knight
takes Bishop takes rook takes and then
when I recapture they get this guy
no but I can insert a check here here
here check first
I don't know you're using a lot of time
now they have to take the night they are
taking the night
now let's just take the Queen we're
taking like that
take the light square bishop
and let's play like this I'll be up the
exchange I'll grab that pawn he's passed
now and now just some control
my bishop could defend
don't need a castle here
open up the a file oh hang on
let's let's get out of harm's way
fearful my bishop running out of squares
open up some new lines
here's good night here this first get my
beep on rolling then Bishop b3
let's get this a pawn rolling stop
Knight here into here
flush the bishop back first
now open up the H file
some checks
[Music]
about here force this
you
Bishop back this can fall right away
might be given some more material back
if this probably capture and then here
yeah this is nearby
your first or take here first they're
not doing anything about that
the pond pressure on the night there's
no time for this they resign
okay under six just a game or two to go
let's see who we got Ferrari might be
the last one I think he just finished
his game
who's got a couple speed bumps there at
the end
elec sir is now in first no sincerity
rules one of the
team chess network fans
good player
we have a French tarush
okay let's get these moves in standard
stuff
[Music]
you
let's I want to keep still queenside
castles open
let's go here
stop any night g5 I guess
you
before nearby here's the thing if I get
these the be pons exchange I miss that
that was a move
all right let's change gears if the B
ponds were exchanged I was going to say
a knight here captures
the long diagonal is open prepared to
recapture with the night to fight off a
night on this square it's a good move
also hang up this square which is scary
you
huh
you
all right let's go here I think my King
needs to book
you
okay this is this is happening soon
Nate h5
here
I think they should take here
first or something with this undermining
this structure
keep my eyes peeled open
or something
even on the clock
yeah that's another variation
take on g2 I probably should
stuffed take like this I want to be able
to castle
move forward
we're moving forward don't want to put
pressure here
yeah maybe here for once this is
captured may be my queen gets to see
three bishop takes
Bishop takes
you
who
you
okay Bishop g5 I
is happening No
let's go here
pressure here
takes b4
take
try this this break unprotected bishop
let's get out for this in case there's a
promotion with check
and this guy
Queen is thankfully not playing yet
and a break
threatening a fork they got two passers
what a wild finish my knight has a
square
it's my king doing all right
my Brooke could be hit okay they're
taking like that I like that decision
take take with the Queen have this take
with the pawn oh I have this check
lock with the clean we're going to enter
an ending no
my night playing
20 seconds I have a check
here
I'm made if the Queen gets too crazy
take care
a ship takes pawn
this guy
rook here would have been better
Bishop I should have played there I have
a night check for me
bishop here
and I give a check they're taking that
one take that night
ah down on time what a finish
good game that got so wild
good game
ah
they kicked it in such a high
faster gear there did I have mate right
there
I must have had me here right here night
check here and then here is me
ah good game that got so sharp
nice good games all that was fun that
was good
you